this week on quadriga
1914 to 2014 a century of history they
were events that changed the course of
history 2014 marks the 100th anniversary
of the outbreak of the First World War
75 years ago Europe was once again
plunged into conflict as the armies of
Nazi Germany marched into Poland and
ignited World War two
and it's been 25 years since the most
important event in recent German history
the fall of the Berlin Wall and the
lifting of the Iron Curtain there are
some of the most defining events in
modern history but how are they
connected and what is their impact on
modern-day Germany your host this week
Melinda Crain Happy New Year and welcome
to Quad Riga the fall of the Berlin Wall
was famously referred to by one American
political scientist in 1989 as the end
of history the notion that the end of
the Cold War would usher in an era of
eternal peace to use Immanuel Kant's
phrase now looks a little utopian indeed
the world of 2014 is at least as
turbulent as that of 1989 so turbulent
that comparisons are warranted between
the world of 2014 and that of 1914 and
in preparing for the changes ahead of us
what can we learn from the successes and
the disasters of the past century that's
what we want to talk about today on
quadriga
with three people who follow events and
developments in Germany and Europe very
closely
starting with Philipp Gessler he works
for the broadcaster Deutsche Bank audio
and he wrote his doctorate in history on
the culture of memory his fields of
emphasis are religion and society and
I'm very pleased to welcome Leslie call
it he's an American journalist and
writer who's lived and worked in Berlin
since 1968
reporting on Germany for media outlets
such as the British newspaper The
Observer as well as the Financial Times
and it's a great pleasure to welcome
Pascal Luc to the program she writes
frequently on franco-german relations
she began her career at the BBC World
Service and she subsequently wrote for
the French paper liberation and the news
magazine laQuan Philip Kessler 2014 as
we saw in that report of course a
century since the beginning of World War
1 75 years since the beginning of World
War two is it going to be a tough year
for Germany
as these events are commemorated yes
surely and there will be a lot of
remembrance but in the end the history
showed off quite well for Germany in the
end everything went out quite well so we
will look back a lot I think but in the
end we will see that from these starting
points of our history let's say at the
moment we are in very happy times
therefore I think there will be a lot of
remembrance but also some views ahead
Leslie College you have experienced much
of that turbulence that transformation
of Germany on a very personal level you
were here in Germany as a boy then you
returned as a reporter when there was
still rubble in German cities tell us
something about that transformation as
you have witnessed it well the Germans
that I experienced as a boy in 1949 were
totally demoralized they couldn't
foresee that this country would ever
really rise again to what it is anything
remotely like it is now at the same time
they had also lost their memory they
they were complaining a great deal about
the suffering which they had gone
through through the Second World War
they were pacifists because of that not
pacifist because of what this country
had had done in the way of of starting
the war but simply because of the the
immense suffering which they felt that
they had gone through this all changed
young generation in Germany came up
which rejected those values of their of
their elders and created basically the
Germany we know today without them
rising up in the 60s and 70s it would be
a different country today and I think
because of that we can be very sure I
think that that Germany is on a path
which is which is one
of not only peace but of good leadership
in Europe memory and identity Pascal
something that you have written about a
number of times in your books on Germany
France and their relations with one
another
how will France be commemorating these
enormous events of this year and what do
they mean for the French identity it's
very different to Germany of course the
first world war when you have pictures
of the end of the war 1918 the Germans
go back they've lost the war they go
back home it's a defeat it's a tragedy a
lot have died the French a lot have died
as well but they they walk on the
boulevards in of big French cities and
it's a triumph and if you walk through
French cities every French city has at
least five or six streets big streets of
bull bars which carries the name of a
general in the in the French army in the
first world war of Forsch Peter not
anymore but was a little hiccup
so the first world war is an extreme and
it's a founding mile of the French
identity some something everybody's
proud about it's a legend I mean there
was not one Christmas Eve evening at
home Christmas supper where you wouldn't
talk the uncle of the grandfather
wouldn't talk about his first world war
the second world war is a little bit
complicated because we didn't really win
you can say that it was very abruptly
finished and we collaborated that it
took us a lot of time in France to - and
we are still working on this on this
very very gloomy and very difficult
period of our history but on the whole
it's going to be a
would your celebration and I hope I hope
because the French haven't done this
work on their history that the Germans
have done I hope that there will be a
lot of question arising as well about
the Second World War and the commitment
of the of the French government in the
in the Nazi I'm in the collaboration
that still I think in a lot of French
families are taboo subjects philip
kessler as i mentioned you wrote your
doctorate on the culture of memory tell
us something about what that means for
germans today
leslie call it reminded us that there
was a kind of collective amnesia in 1949
a great difficulty in many many german
families to look back at the past to
talk about responsibility or lack
thereof has that changed what does it
mean for germans today well first of all
the first war first world war was a
little bit forgotten in the last decades
it's only in the last let's say ten
years that the remembrance are coming
back and it's only by historians because
all the people who really seen it or
survived it are dead now therefore the
the most important or more important is
the Second World War I really do think
as mr. Collins said that there was a in
Asia there was great fear to look back
at the Second World War and at the
Holocaust and it took about one
generation to overcome this fear to look
back and still there's a lot to be
learnt by the Second World War and by
the Holocaust but seen altogether I
think Germany is quite in a good way and
maybe it's good now that we are able to
look at the First World War as well
again because this was the starting
point of this horrible 20th century with
all the ideal logic
ideologies and all the mass murders that
occurred therefore if we could learn
something from the world first world war
I think for example the the very
dangerous path that every country is
going if it's having an arms race for
example with another country this is
always very very dangerous and that's
one of the things we can learn today to
avoid this historians are in fact
rethinking some of the theories about
the causality of the first world war for
decades it was simply assumed that there
- Germany was the perpetrator
Leslee call it do you think we are
seeing a shift now in that
interpretation and if so what kind of a
difference might that make for Germans
if any at all well it's a bit late for
in other words - to say that Germans are
going to be influenced very much today
by the cause of the first world war but
it definitely has come to that that the
that Germany is seen as because of its
links with austro-hungary
have been sucked into a war it really
didn't want to enter in the first place
but on the other hand the the fact was
that that the when it started it was
backed wholly by the population as it
was in France as it was in England as it
was in the United States everybody
backed their own their own side there
was very little resistance and to the to
the fact that war broke out and I think
that's what has changed today in that
you have a very reluctant population in
the United States today after a series
of terrible mishaps in starting with
Iraq then going on to Afghanistan the
the population is simply not in the mood
anymore it took a long time for this to
happen
Germany it went very quickly the end of
the Second World War was so disastrous
for Germany that it's learned a lesson
for hundreds of years probably if not
thousands probably someone once compared
with the Vikings once they had finished
with their pillaging of
of Italy and Sicily and so on and and
and we're certainly burned out for
history now they're considered the
Scandinavians are considered
peace-loving and I think this is the
legacy for Germany as well and also I
think you have to remember the eve of
the first world war this immense climate
of nationalism in not only in Germany
but in France for one of my books I
studied the the I read a lot of the
school of curved talks from from French
generals and also newspapers and the
climate was incredibly I mean they would
even in official newspaper you would
never call the Germans the Germans but
the Bosch which is a very very nasty
nickname for the Germans and you
wouldn't expect that to be in the speech
of a general you know you would you
would maybe think it but you would use
normal diplomatic language so you have
to remember and this has changed
completely I mean especially between
France and Germany but you're right I
mean in Germany but in France I think
everybody has this memory as well even
if we didn't suffer as much or if we
were but nobody wants to go anymore and
nobody's as nationalistic you have the
formation aisle you have a few parties
but it's not as as well precisely and we
say it couldn't ever happen again but in
fact we're seeing predictions Philip
Kessler that in the next European
Parliament there could be up to 25%
far-right extremist parties represented
are we so sure that nationalism could
not rear its head again in Europe no
nationalism was always in Europe and
will be always there as long as we live
I think but the difference to 1914 is
that there's no really great cheers
about war as mr. Collins and as
colleague said you might remember that
even the intellectuals like Thomas Mann
for example and embraced the war and
said this is a moment of
purification of clearness of cleaning of
hope and this is unthinkable today I
think in in in Germany and also not in
in France and in the u.s. I think go up
in Berlin told me the story of his
father and many of the of the others
every day moving pins on a map on the
wall of the of the way the German front
was developing in France at that time it
was just a part of the daily life it was
incredible this was very quick I mean I
I have the I got the felt plea from my
grandfather that is proposal letters
from the fields which he wrote in the
German army cos we are as Asians and he
fought in the German army in the first
world war and he was 18 and at the
beginning is yeah he's very enthusiastic
and very quickly he he's the wines like
a little child and he wants to go back
to his mother and he says it doesn't
matter who wins the war I want it to
stop and the good thing about the end of
the Second World War for Germany was
also that the world has learned from the
disaster of Versailles if you like and
the side they really had very hard
conditions for Germany which were
opposed on Germany and then after World
War Two there was the there was plans to
grow up for the growth of the German
economy and therefore this was a lesson
very they learned so there isn't a
feeling in Germany anymore that we have
lost the war and we we will have to have
a relaunch unless they call it of course
there was not complete unanimity on
those plans to revitalize the German
economy indeed there was an early plan
after World War Two morgenthau plan to
actually reduce Germany to an agrarian
society that was quickly rejected remind
us what was it that somehow convinced
George Marshall to to invent his famous
plan to aid Europe to aid a former enemy
quite an astonishing move well partly it
was of course the increase
rivalry with the Soviet Union already in
the early post-war years we could see
that the United States and the Soviet
we're not going to agree about any line
through Europe dividing Eastern and
Western Europe and from that lesson I
think grew the recognition that Germany
was going to be a key to this anyway as
the leading industrial country even in
defeat it was going to it was inevitable
that you had to help this country and it
was some people say it was an economic
decision which America knew would profit
itself because they've had to have
somebody but the trade with otherwise
who are you going to deal with in Europe
but but the economic economically
prosperous countries and the Marshall
Plan is what kicked it all off yeah
Pascal you another absolutely defining
element of the post-war order that
developed on the ashes of World War 2
was of course the franco-german alliance
also inconceivable to many people that
these two former enemies could become
such close friends now Angela Merkel
went to France just before Christmas her
very first state visit after she was
sworn in for her third term as
Chancellor but many people in Germany
feel that today France is perhaps the
sick man of Europe so to speak how
strong is that franco-german
partnership now and is is it perhaps in
danger of weakening more than at any
point since we have known it since the
second world war it's become much more
complicated because you have to remember
since the second world after the Second
World War it was very clear German was a
political dwarf and an economic giant
and France was a middle economic giant
but a political leader and so you had a
you know France France was there and
Germany was there and since the
unification Germany has become much more
confidence is much more at ease with its
identity
it's is proud of its economic
successes and France is declining France
is in the you know real crisis I mean
the economy is not doing very well
we have identity problem which are
massive and which explains also the rise
of the of the four national and and so
the balance has changed and it's very
difficult now to I wouldn't say it's
weakening and it's more complicated it
has to be worked out you have to find
another modus of communicating and and
and to accept I think it's more for me
it's more French than a German problem
the French a French have to accept that
Germany is not a dwarf anymore that it's
a partner on equal terms and that's
quite difficult for us you reminded us
of the importance of the French world of
the First World War for the French
identity clearly France still longs to
be seen by itself and others as lagonda
fuel it's in engages in military
activities in Africa almost still as a
post-colonial power to what degree is
all of that nostalgia you ask me I've
been living abroad for the for many many
years so I have a haven't got a very
French look I look at it with distance
and I find it some sometimes ludicrous
and when I'm used now to German
politicians being very low-key very
unpatriotic and when I hear mr. shock
mr. mittai Hall I remember she happened
he was quoting to office says the Franz
LaHood of near la falda pretty moon
France has to become again the the
lighthouse of of the world I mean no
German political it's not only it didn't
mean it wasn't dangerous but it's
ludicrous it's ridiculous how can you
you know and these pathos this emphasis
you know that in human relationship as
well when somebody's doing a bit too
much and very loud and actually it's a
sign of low self-esteem and I think that
presidents I mean or not is a little bit
better but that French but look at
Sarkozy you know all these wind and all
these words and all this you know
affirming that we are laugh horse and
shows that we are not so self confidence
as we pretend and what about Germany
Philip
Germany of course commanded by us here
in this program but also by many many
historians and philosophers throughout
the world for its confrontation with
history the Germans have a special word
for it
the Galleon heights parvati gong the
attempt after the Second World War to
come to terms with the past and with the
pain and suffering and sin if you would
that Germany had perpetrated where does
Germany stand today in terms of its own
identity well I think it's getting a
little bit better as you hike still the
past is very present and in Germany and
the Second World War and the holocaust
it's better as well but as you know the
reunification is now about 20-25 years
ago and these this also had an impact
that there's now this discussion now
about maybe the new role that Germany
has to play in the world or in Europe
I'm not sure whether the really the
German politician politicians want to
play this role do they really want to
rule Europe
I don't think so they would like to be
very very strong and healthy nation but
do they want to play the ruling the
ruling part I don't think so and they
would like to do it I think with France
and at the moment that's a little bit
difficult that's true that seeing the
the lemme T of Hong Kuen owned the the
German French friendship I think it's
very important to see that this has also
grown from from the ground if there
wouldn't be so many human large
connections between little villages in
Germany and in France this friendship
wouldn't be so strong as it still is so
I'm very confident and that this
friendship will overcome the the next
decades and will be stronger in the last
decades also as we were reminded by the
report at the top of our program Germany
will also this year be commemorating the
25th anniversary of the fall of the wall
it has a young generation coming to
adulthood who were born after
unification so how the scars of the
division entirely healed
let's take a look November 9th 1989
after months of protests thousands of
East Germans converged on checkpoints
into West Berlin in response the
Communist leadership opened the border
the Berlin wall had been breached it
marked the beginning of the end of the
Iron Curtain a quarter of a century on
only traces of the wall remain but is
the east-west divide really a thing of
the past East Germans aren't any
different flu there are more differences
between north and south I'm at home in
eastern Germany the West is a foreign
country to me German reunification a
success story or still a work in
progress
let me call it how would you answer that
last question is unification still a
work in progress or would you say that
it is now very much simply a part of the
fabric of normal German life it's yeah
both actually many problems remain but
the basic division is is has been
overcome successfully I think because in
in many ways of in many ways Germany is
a a more it's definitely a more sane
country than it was before the division
it's a more content country than it was
then it's more livable it's in every way
yes a
a better country to guide the rest of
Europe in the way I talk about this is
because the franco-german alliance seems
to be faltering to such an extent that
there is a need for German leadership
and it's being shown daily I mean after
all for Merkel has the has the gift of
not making it look as if she is trying
to to lead Europe but for want of any
other leadership she has to do it and
she's doing it very successfully and
she's not exactly loved in Greece and
and in Spain but they're they're
learning the lessons slowly because
their elites
failed on them that was the the why
they're in the in the situation they are
and today and until they repair that's
that that fault things aren't going to
get better permanently and I think
Germany can teach in its very modest way
a lot through the rest of Europe and
maybe to also the rest of the world but
the question is whether the rest of
Europe at least Pascal who is really
ready to see Germany take on that role
you mentioned france's own ambivalence
about the shift in relative power and
certainly many people feel germany
continues to punch under its weight in
terms of leadership both in Europe and
globally
it's Germany's is in a very very
difficult position because if it leads
everybody gets up and say you know the
shadows of the past
they are authoritarian they want to have
it their ways if they don't do anything
they're accused of being passive and not
interested in not committed and shifting
to zonda vague or you know an alone
so it's very very difficult but I don't
think I mean I taking the French I don't
know in Britain but the French find it
very difficult when the Germans are
leading you know if they lead we can't
lead as well and it's so it's so it's a
big it's a big problem at the moment and
if you see I'm amazed at the campaign in
Poland in Greece in France when that you
every every third week you have a
cartoon or a political edition who
compares Angela Merkel with Bismarck
that's so already absurd but and with
Hitler and it's you know who has ever
complained miss Yolanda Monsieur Sarkozy
was pizza nobody would dare you know and
she says my family is so laid-back she
says you know we will live in a
democracy she let it so that which I
find remarkable because it's it's and
it's an incredible insult I mean
actually it's it's impossible to say
something like that so it's very it's
more I think it's more of a problem of a
so of foreign countries then of Germany
that we are very yeah we don't let them
do but I would be very cautious that
Germany would could teach anything into
the world that's thinking really before
the first world war that on the
Deutschland reasons OD vet Keynesian on
the German spirit the whole world should
heal should be healed I really don't
think that Germany has to give so much
lesson lessons that's a thinking of an
old world I think the the mange by
example not teach in the sense of you
know wagging a finger and in that way in
the economy I mean I we don't have
French Britain don't want you know you
always talk about German economic
successes but you would want to want to
learn from them culturally do we want
them in there and politically there are
so many other fields but that my mention
of the sense that Germany often punches
under its weight phil kessel of course
also very much connected to the German
reluctance to become involved militarily
in other countries as I said France
going with alacrity to Mali when it's
needed something Germany is extremely
reluctant to do do you think we will see
that change going forward and is that
part of perhaps a necessary form of
German leadership given our increasingly
turbulent world well I'm not sure
because as you've seen in Afghanistan
where Germany is since 10 years now this
reluctance is crumbling down and in the
last year's and I'm not sure whether
really the militarization of foreign
policy is a good path to be to be
followed it might be that the German
army has to go with allies France on the
u.s. to other hotspots or to other walls
in the world maybe also to to Africa but
this isn't something that I would like
to see I think the the foreign policy of
the future must be more clever and as we
have seen in Afghanistan after 10 years
the outcome is not very very good in the
end this is a recognition that most
Germans do have that it was it was the
wrong thing to do
right well in the beginning there was
the feeling I think 10 years ago it
might be a good thing but as for example
Margaret kaseman a leading figure of the
Protestant church in Germany said
nothing is good in Afghanistan she was
heavily beaten by saying this but if you
ask some people some Germans there were
for example working there as
for helping organizations they say well
in the end it wasn't so wrong what she
said
I think the Germans increasingly take
the attitude if there has to be a fight
let them do it because it's going to
work in the world I asked at the outset
of the program whether we are looking
toward such turbulence ahead that we
might well say 2014 represents the same
kind of tectonic shift in the world
order that we saw in 1914 1914 of course
the end of the world order as it was
known at the time and the slow birth of
a new one is that new one now coming to
an end let me call it we don't know that
is I mean these tectonic shifts are said
to be this and that but can we be sure I
mean just as the prediction that the
wall the end of the division of Europe
was going to herald a new a new era in
history we don't know what's going to
happen in China for instance do we know
whether this increasingly daily to be
seen drive for more democracy in China
where is that going to lead can can it
will be perhaps witness a new rise in
turbulence in China because of this a
population which which has to take
things in its own grasp because the the
leaders refused to give the democracy
which they want well what what that
could mean in in in in turbulence in
Asia and what is the West going to do
then we can't interfere in internal
Chinese relations a hundred and eighty
years after the Boxer war what can we do
what will be the relations between India
and China India also has won 1.2 billion
people here here on earth would you say
from the experience that we saw in the
past hundred years Philip Gessler that a
shift in power like the one we're seeing
now and that one that occurred in 1914
as the German Kaiser I rose to power
eclipsing England economically
militarily or at least becoming a true
rival associated with terrible violence
at that time must such a shift ahead of
us also be accompanied by violence no I
don't think so because the globalization
of the world of the economic sphere is
so strong that even China's in some ways
very cautious compared with the
abilities they have China for example is
more interested in good trading
condition than in political power it
seems and if this is true and will be
true in the last decades I don't think
that really 1914 could be compared with
2014 I think in a way over our world is
more safe than it was 100 years ago
Pascal you get that sense of searching
for identity in France that sense
perhaps of potential decline do you
think that reflects a real decline for
Europe as a whole in terms of its
position in the world does the rise of
new powers automatically mean the
decline of the old ones very European
and I'm very optimistic so I will and
answer no I think coming back to the
specific French problem we have European
election soon and I'm very frightened
because you know the danger that the
fuel Nacional the rash right extreme
party will score very well and that's
you know I can't look in the future like
that I find it difficult but I can look
in the next few months and that's that's
very frightening that's very very
frightening and I think France should
tackle this problem and I hope I hope
that the French voters will come to
reason and not vote for the phone
Nationale but it's France has changed a
lot in the past 10 20 20 years for 20
years it was nobody would say allowed de
voto nacional now everybody i mean it's
a very it's a very power to party which
is accepted by everyone and which is
playing a very big role a sense of
decline of
Leslee call it subjectively even if it
does not reflect perhaps absolute
circumstances but a subjective sense of
decline is a powerful driver for extreme
politics is it not and are we seeing
some of that even in your own country in
the US I don't think so at least under
the present administration there's more
feeling of of helplessness really we're
looking at a phenomenon which is
worldwide leaders today simply have less
influence on the on the course of
history than they used to they're not
molders of history anymore that they're
kind of riding on a wave of history and
not knowing where it's taking them
really I would say that that that
feeling some people might say that's
dangerous because there is no one power
anymore which can determine events such
as you had after the Second World War no
super power left really I don't see the
United States as a it may be still a
superpower in military terms but that
doesn't mean it can really decide what
is happening in the Middle East as we
can see just a series of failures every
intervention every attempt to bring
about peace there simply doesn't work
indeed there's a theory of to us
political scientists they refer to the
world that's ahead of us as the g0 world
not g8 not g20 but basically a
leaderless vacuum Philip Kessler if that
is the case let's bring it back now
again to Germany and Europe their role
in the world and what we can learn out
of the successes of the past century
going forward what would be the
essential components that we need to be
need to be aware of as we look at how to
navigate through this vacuum well I'm
not sure whether there really is a
vacuum there's no vacuum in power
normally maybe the power has
shift shifted to multilateral big
companies maybe there now is the big
power and not with politicians the the
world is getting complicated more
complicated and then it was after the
second world war but in my point of view
that's just quite normal
we are in a way we are going back to
normality that the there are many
players in in the world and if the
politicians are not as powerful as they
were the beginning of the first world
war where it was also a failure of the
political leaders for example the the
emperor wilhelm ii was a disaster
disaster in politics i think this could
be quite good if more or less
democracies or strong nations are
leading and not some very important
figures i thought you told us she was an
optimist how do you see it when you look
ahead
there's a wonderful german world called
ackward called sucrose pessimist moss
which is basically the sense that
everything ahead of us is necessarily
going to be worse than what was what was
in the past how would you see it
I think Nietzsche said everybody who was
pessimistic is just realistic but that's
not true I'm also tending like Pascal it
to be quite optimistic I really can't
see apart from the maybe the ecological
problems where we will face that it will
really will be more dangerous the decays
ahead than we had in the decades before
the the ideologies are gone more or less
we are the awareness that we are living
on a very small planet and that we have
to work together because everything else
won't work is rising everywhere
therefore maybe there's a day in there
with
with China and the military there but it
can't be foreseen and if there's any
democracy or democratic movement in
China it could be a big gain for for the
whole world and so I'm optimistic you
have children I know when you look to
the future of course we mothers we often
think about our children and what the
world will be for them and how they will
see the world what would you say is
different about the identity of your
children than perhaps in generations
past the world is bigger go vote is
begun when I was a the age of my
children I was very lucky because I
could go to England we had family in
England so and that was so exotic I came
from Strasbourg I went to England now
they go to New Zealand they go to Canada
they want to live maybe in America and I
find that great and in this Franco drum
and everybody says well they don't learn
German anymore the French don't grow
from the German don't learn French yes
but daily they learn English they learn
Spanish they may be Chinese or Arabic
and I find it it's it's a little bit you
have to have a good sense of place to go
very far away like that but it's great
that the world has often is so often and
I think you have to push them out and to
make them inquisitive and you see I'm an
optimistic Lesley call it this word that
I mentioned suka pessimism was pessimism
about the future often said something to
be something that older people are
somewhat more susceptible to when you
look toward the future on the basis of
the extreme turbulence that you have
witnessed yourself in the years that you
have been in Europe what is your
expectation and how optimistic or
pessimistic are you well basically I am
optimistic particularly with with
hindsight as you say the the past was
definitely not exactly a blessing for
Europe and things are on the right track
I think it's going to be a hard slog as
they say it's not going to be easy to
overcome the differences in an economic
group
in northern Europe and southern Europe
those are all problems which are going
to take years to to surmount but I think
in the end Europe will come out and
surprise the rest of the world with the
critics in in in in some parts of the
world have always pointed to Europe and
have said it's a declining decaying
continent I haven't I don't see any much
decay and it's it's vibrant it's
changing yes there are these right-wing
movements but there are ultra
conservative movements everywhere who
want to go back to the the past I think
Europe is definitely going to surprise
us all many thanks optimistic last words
for an optimistic New Year's program I'm
very grateful to all of you for being
with us and all of you out there for
tuning in see you soon and Happy New
Year
you